il faut bien rire après il faut bien
rire un rire un peu à propos du rire il
faut tout même je vous le dise parce que
c'est important
à propos parce que le rire comme chacun
sait vous de ces prêts
le rire c'est une énergie contenue qui
n'a pas de quoi rire c'est une énergie
contenue qui se libèrent rapidement bon
et en se libérant elle fait vibrer les
muscles et plus vulnérables les plus
fragiles qui se trouvent être des
zygomatiques avril exactement bravo
monsieur et va supposer que les muscles
fessiers et bénéficieront n'a pas
l'effectif soit plus vulnérables que les
zygomatiques
eh bien on verrait comme ça on l'a fait
vous voyez une salle cuiry désopilant je
pouffe un risque mais après tout la fin
ri aux éclats je vois pas très bien quoi
sa chorale ans
on l'a échappé belle toute attention nos
ancêtres y est comme ça nos ancêtres et
primitif comme l'homme des cavernes le
rire caverneux noms et les primitifs les
primitifs il rit je n'ai rien contre les
produits ticks je n'ai rien contre les
primitifs qu'ils ont tout inventé
ils ont tout inventé la pierre taillée
qui est ce qu'il inventait la pierre
taillée un prix qui le feu qui inventent
elle veut imprimer qui s'est établi à
110 villages alors un jour il a pris de
pierres une dans chaque main aux
innocents les mains pleines vous allez
affronter une perruque contrôle comme ça
tout s'est fait des étincelles
alors le chef un primitif outils ou
cherche primitif mais chef
tout d'abord il a vu que du feu c'est à
dire qu'il a vu de la fumée mais comme
il ya pas de fumée sans feu et nadine
aller chercher le sorcier pour changer
car yeux un chakri primitif
il ya eu des primitifs à l'époque élus
des techniciens
leur chef à l'isf est innocent il a dit
aline aux anglais revêt refait devant le
sorcier ce que tu nous as fait elle en
liaison avec cette petite pierre ziegler
fait petite flambée sur le le sorcier a
dit feu de dieu
ça sent le roussi
il a joué avec les amulettes il faut le
brûler alors le chef indien coi et
l'autre innocent il a dit avec ça il a
vu le feu au bûcher qu'on venait de
dresser pour lui alors autour du bus les
primitifs
il s'appelle derrière par terre alors la
réflexion qu'il espère enfin
heureusement qu'il n'a pas inventé la
poudre
parce qu'en prix de leur nul aurait
fallu le faire sauter on utilise sa
peine derrière plus fort que les autres
ça lui a durci les fessiers le les
fessiers sont lus moins vulnérable que
les zygomatiques
le rire lui est monté à la gorge et l'a
fait il avait inventé le rire
montez dans l'antre mythique les
primitifs ont tout inventé de la roue la
roue la roue les huits le fusain c'est
tout de même un primitif qui le premier
a dessiné sur la paroi de la caverne
bison futé avec des flèches ou la vache
qui rit sont tout inventé des prix
plutôt et moi moi moi qui suis évoluer
si quel jeu inventé voici tout de même
parce que tout même l'histoire telle que
je viens de vous la conter ses voix
qu'il y en avoir